Donald Trump's world is crumbling around
him he doesn't understand anything he's
furious all the time he doesn't
understand how viruses work how vaccines
work how masks work how Lysol and bleach
and isopropyl alcohol work and he spent
his entire weekend tweeting everything
from retweeting his own tweets to
pushing qyn on conspiracy theories to
attacking Barack Obama and the media at
one point listen to these numbers Trump
sent 52 tweets and retweets in an hour
that is almost one tweet per minute
Trump sent more than 50 tweets over the
weekend about the Russia investigation
Trump sent over a hundred tweets in a
single day I am NOT going to subject you
to all of these the content is mostly
irrelevant for our understanding of how
hard this dude is failing but check out
some of these are completely out of
control man without common sense or
inhibitions retweeting endless
conspiratorial attacks on Barack Obama
and the FBI for the Russia probe we have
some of them on the screen the content
is mostly irrelevant these are the
rantings of a madman and that's how they
should be interpreted continuing about
one tweet per minute sometimes three or
four or even five tweets in a single
minute Trump even retweeting his own
tweets from hours earlier we can't
possibly go through hundreds of Donald
Trump's tweets nor would it make sense
to the content again is not really the
focus here but the gist of this so that
you understand the next wave of
propaganda the gist of what we saw over
the weekend is that Donald Trump is now
renewing his claim and his focus on the
entire Russia investigation being a
calculated illegal conspiracy involving
Barack Obama to end his presidency and
unfortunately and this is why as I spoke
about it in the last segment I fear that
Trump is somehow going to figure out a
way to get himself reelected this could
be
the perfect distraction from the fact
that almost 81 thousand people as of
this morning have already died from
coronavirus and that number continues to
climb last week Donald Trump's Justice
Department decided they're not going to
go forward with the prosecution of
Michael Flynn Donald Trump's disgraced
former national security adviser
understand that Flynn pleaded guilty and
the Justice Department has decided in
what is one of the most overtly corrupt
actions of the Trump presidency
hey we aren't going to move forward the
case against them isn't that strong he
pleaded guilty so now they're using this
absolutely corrupt decision by Trump's
Attorney General William bar to try to
revitalize the case that the entire
Russia investigation was bogus illegal
it was Obama's illegal plan and on and
on and on Fox News regularly over the
weekend using the term bombshell so
we're gonna talk about a bunch of
different things here number one I'd
briefly on the Michael Flynn thing if
Donald Trump had pardoned Michael Flynn
it would have been another one of these
sick corrupt elements of Donald Trump's
cronyism and nepotism and everything he
said that he would root out that he
actually embodies but it would have been
less concerning then Trump's Attorney
General coming in and saying about a
case that was built up over years were
you achieved a guilty plea yeah we're
not gonna prosecute that anymore
that's a level of corruption involving
the Justice Department that is actually
far scarier than Trump simply pardoning
his friend or his guy and will have more
time to talk about that a few other
things that that we need to talk about
first of all a hundred and twenty five
tweets in one day fifty two tweets in an
hour people who work fast food people
who teach school people who work in
factories me everybody I know who has a
job none of them have time to tweet 52
times in an hour even people whose job
it is to tweet
typically don't tweet 52 times in an
hour this is not normal behavior it has
to be stopped and there's only one way
to stop it and you know it and I know it
and it's happening about five and a half
months from now
number two the Republican Senate must be
punished for this in November I know
that there's a lot of focus on Trump but
if it weren't for the Republican Senate
Trump would have already been removed or
at least could have been removed
remember that impeachment trial last
week I got a call about you know what's
more important than moving Trump or
defeating Republican senators in the
fall you get to vote in both you don't
have to pick I'm voting in the
presidential or I'm voting in the Senate
election it's in all of the above
situation Republicans must be punished
they aren't just complicit they're
actively involved there's a whole bunch
of Republican senators martha mcsalley
susan collins cory gardner you know
we've talked about the whole list of
them they could all be removed in
addition to removing Donald Trump and
then lastly we're in the midst of a
hundred year pandemic and Trump is
failing in his handling of that pandemic
and he tweeted a hundred more than a
hundred times in one day if anyone did
anything like this at work if a
firefighter was tweeting while a house
was burning down if an airline pilot was
tweeting during an emergency landing
anybody else would be fired from this
they would be removed from their job
depending on what the costs were of
their distraction they would be
criminally prosecuted and we need to
make sure that Trump is held accountable
in the only possible way that he's going
to be held accountable I believe part of
what might have set Trump off this
particular weekend is Barack Obama
lashing out at Trump about his handling
of coronavirus and that's what I want to
talk about next check this out the first
500 people who see this video and go to
david pakman.com slash skill will get a
premium membership to Skillshare for two
months completely free skill shares the
online learning community with thousands
of classes on almost anything you can
imagine
always taught by experts they have
classes on drawing painting photography
video editing web design running a small
business and much more I recently took a
very interesting class called simple
productivity how to accomplish more with
less and got a bunch of great personal
productivity tips out of it we should
allow ourselves a little time every week
to either get creative keep your brain
sharp learn something new it's great for
mental health and almost all the classes
are under an hour so it's very easy for
someone who's busy to take advantage of
it with skill share you can discover a
new passion explore something you didn't
know you would enjoy but there's also
plenty of classes for people with
experience so you can just get better at
something you're already good at and
again the first 500 people who see this
video and go to david pakman.com slash
skill will get a completely free premium
membership for two whole months giving
you access to every class Skillshare
offers check it out I put the link right
underneath this video